hey guys it's christian serrados i play
selena hi my name is gabriel chavarria
and i play a b quintanilla hi
i'm ricardo chavira and i play abraham
quintanilla hi i'm noemi gonzalez i play
susette quintanilla
hi i am sadie lopez and i play marcella
quintanilla
we are here with buzzfeed to share our
selena hot takes
which is selena's best studio album
selena ben conmigo mundo amor
that's because you're my son because
you're my son and you you know
you know what dad is right for me is one
of selena's biggest biggest
album that has most of her biggest hits
in there and that's uh
the the the songs most of the songs a b
world the unique talent that was
was a b quintanilla as a as a songwriter
i would say
selena i would say amor wow you were
right it was
there it is yeah streaming the view is
up there too though
oh really my other one was like on the
bottom fascinating
yeah i mean that has all the classic
songs someone froy though so i'm not
surprised
which is selena's most iconic signature
look bangs
bedazzled jean jacket bold red lips
booster tops
giant hoop earrings high-waisted pants
i'm going to say the bedazzle jean
jacket
most of the super slinging fans they all
have the dazzle jean jackets
for me it's the red lips of all the
images and everything that we see
the one thing that was always constantly
true were the red lips
red lips i love to say red lips because
i'm obviously honoring her right now
but i think i'm going to say bustier
tops
tops she invented that hey i picked the
top three yeah i think
her the boosted toxic she was the first
person to really do that i think she was
such
an innovator which is selena's greatest
music video
amor prohibido bambam como la flor
no me que damas i wanna say no me que da
mas
me too it's got to be coming off-road
live from astronaut yeah i'm going to
say no
let's see what happens but i'm going to
go with amor
because that has like a special place in
my heart after shooting this show
itty-bitty bum
became such like a emotional song for me
it's what i sang
in like the screen test and was choking
back tears and we had a lot of great
review moments on the show so that's
definitely become one of my favorite
songs and also my favorite song to sing
like as me as christian
well i lost that one wow which is
selena's
best ballad dreaming of you i could fall
in love
no me i know what most people are going
to pick they're going to pick nomas
but i'm going to pick dreaming of you
because
that's one of my favorite if not my
favorite
english selena song i'm gonna have to go
and i'm gonna get a mask
was last everyone loves normal mass i'm
so surprised it's like everyone's
favorite song
which is selena's best dance track
el chico
me too the lyrics are literally
telling you this song is for you to move
your body like get down like and
and it literally calls out the people
that are like mira maria
for eating too much tortilla you know
like it really calls out people to like
oh if someone is in their chair
knock that chair out out from under them
get them on the dance floor
i'm gonna go with techno [ __ ] yeah
because that is my favorite song and i'm
telling you there's a reason why it's up
here
it is the best song to dance to i'm
gonna say bitty bitty bum bum because i
think that's gonna be the one
i'm gonna say because
i don't feel like it ever gets enough
credit and it's such a good
song oh my goodness
what is going on yeah very very bum bum
yeah of course
i mean yeah you go off to dvd it's such
a good song which is selena's best
breakup jam
for me because i love the way selena
performed it on one of her performances
that she did
and i really loved the way christian
arsenal performed it so i'm gonna go
with cinavez
i'm gonna go with uh la la la mala
100 150
you think of a breakup song and you
think of selena it is an empowering
breakup song yes that's right baby oh it
was a lot of passion
sorry i really love that which is
selena's most heart-wrenching song
i'm going to say no every time that song
plays i notice
people tear up no making them easily i
am going to go with como laflore because
that is my absolute favorite sabine song
and i'm just a romantic at heart and i
think it's
absolutely heart-wrenching one of my
favorites is photos
so because it's my favorite song i'm
gonna go with photos
yeah all that is right yeah they're all
good they're all heart-wrenching and all
beautiful
which is the most iconic selena duet
buenos amigos with alvaro torres
with barrio boyz all right i'm gonna go
with buenos amigos i'm gonna go with the
barrio boys one just because i've always
liked that it got played time and time
and time again over in south texas in
san antonio
that's an iconic song for me i think
donde quieres
que tes i'm gonna say buenos amigos oh
my gosh
not the popular vote but that's okay i
legit remember
barrio boys and i remember selena
working with with this boy band
and it felt so mexican-american with
this
time where we had the backstreet boys in
sync and and that selena was with them
it felt very much like britney working
with
and singing and you start and you
started to feel a little bit that
transition of the crossover
who gave the best live selena cover
bruno mars dreaming of you
gloria stefan i could fall in love
jennifer lopez nomas casey musgraves
selena gomez
i'm going to go jennifer lopez i think
i'm going to do bruno mars dreaming of
you
i'm gonna go old school and i'm gonna
say gloria estefans i could fall in love
for some reason i want to say that i
could fall in love by gloria
you know i have heard um the selena
gomez
and it was really good you're gonna go
with uh selena gomez's video bum bum
nah girl i have to go with jennifer oh
anna for lopez
you knew it say to you you followed your
dad and lastly we have
which is selena's best hairstyle the
natural
curls the long straightened locks short
bob
any style that includes her signature
bangs i'm going to be puro mexicano the
south texas and say the natural curls
well in the sentence it says
any style that includes her signature
bangs so i'm gonna go with that one i'm
gonna go with the natural curls because
i remember there was a
she did a portrait session and i had
stickers of that portrait session from
the like quarter machine and it was a
picture of her with the cascading curls
so um that's what i'm gonna pick
any style that includes her signature
bags i'm gonna go curls because i loved
wearing
her curls ah people love her bangs i
love all of her looks i think that's
what's cool about
seeing her as a kid like coming into her
own
figuring out what kind of artist she
wanted to be she changed her hair a lot
her look a lot
style a lot and i can totally relate to
that i think most people most like young
people can relate to that to
experimenting
and stuff so that's cool
you